So, what do you guys think is
actually happening
inside your body
when you're having an orgasm?
Your organs
are just shaking.
-Things get bigger and bigger.
-What gets bigger?
There's words
for all those things,
but I forget
what they are.
Like in seventh grade
when you did that science
experiment with the two bottles.
You think vinegar
and baking soda...
Yeah.
...are just rushing
to your vagina.
And you just, "Pssh!"
And that's what happens --
volcano vagina.
Nikki: It seems like most
women don't understand
the science behind
the female orgasm.
So, I sat down
with Dr. Nicole Prause,
a neuroscientist
who was conducting
a groundbreaking study
measuring the female orgasm.
So, you're basically the
Neil deGrasse Tyson of pussy.
Oh, my God.
I hope so.
What is an orgasm?
I have no idea
what an orgasm is.
We don't really know
what exactly triggers it.
We don't actually have
good data on that,
but we can use physical
measurements to see
whether or not a woman
is having contractions
that we think are
the main hallmark of orgasm.
How do you, on your end,
know if a lady
is having an orgasm,
aside from the camera
panning up to the moon?
We put an electric device
into a butt plug.
So, just...
typical Tuesday.
And so,
that probe measures the...
The rhythmic puckering
that happens with orgasms.
-Rhythmic puckering.
-Mm-hmm.
I love
that Paul Simon album.
Can some people
just not have an orgasm,
like Kirk Cameron's wife?
Some people physically just
cannot have orgasms.
Do you think that,
in our future,
we'll see a Viagra
for women?
The companies have been trying
for many years,
and many of them have given up
after spending billions.
So, Big Pharma was trying
to give us orgasms,
and it's just been
really hard
and so they kind of just
gave up.
It honestly -- it sounds like
most men in America.
So, how many women
have you gotten off?
Uh, we've had about 20 women
through the protocol so far.
Nice.
Nikki: Dr. Prause's study
could help countless women,
but as all federal funding
has gone to dick research,
she must rely solely
on volunteers.
So, sign my pussy up.
Have you guys ever used
a butt plug before?
-Finger.
-No.
I've never put anything
up my butt.
Oh, wow.
I'll ask you to insert the butt
plug while you're masturbating.
-Ready to do this?
-Ready to do it.
-Let's plug up the butt.
-Yeah, let's do it.
All right, so,
we're just gonna walk in here.
And you want to go ahead
and hop up on the table.
[ Door closes ]
What's going on in there?
She's got the device in.
Which we can see -- she's moving
around a little bit.
See, that looks like
my grandmother's signature.
-Whew.
-Great, how did it go?
I have been found.
This is like
the Dow Jones.
That was great.
She's flatlining.
It fell out a couple times.
That was a little more action
than what -- Ooh.
That was actually not
too bad.
You feel like it stayed
in okay?
I sat on it
so it didn't come out.
You want to go ahead and put the
device in just like we showed?
Whoa!
Yeah, something's
happening here.
The Rock better get
in a helicopter,
because there is
an earthquake a'coming.
Did you see that movie?
"San Andreas."
It's not that good.
All right, how did it go?
Marvelous.
Nikki:
Now it was my turn.
The pressure was on...my clit.
I'm sorry.
That was -- that was bad.
Since you have on pants,
you're gonna take those off
so you'll be nude
from the waist down.
Keep talking.
And then you put the...
right up in there.
Can I listen to audio
of my boyfriend crying?
That does it for me
for some reason.
Yeah, sure.
It's all up to you now.
You get, like, a good luck
or anything?
-Good luck.
-Thanks, coach.
Nikki: Jesus Christ.
I always got to do this.
Oh, yeah,
it's just you and me, wand.
[ Soft jazz music plays ]
The data was logged,
the numbers were crunched,
and the results...
I'm done.
Hopefully the research
I provided today
will help those
who come after me -- literally.
Would you say that this is a new
frontier, the female orgasm?
Absolutely.
I can't believe this work
wasn't done 40 years ago.
And this is exciting
that we have been
a part of this research.
You know how we sent dogs
to space first?
We're the dogs.
-Bitches.
Yes, Rhoda.
You're a bitch.
You're all bitches.